Musik
Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Ok, bist du bereit? Ich habe gerade eine Gag-Idee gehabt, warte mal kurz, warte mal kurz, warte mal kurz. Das dauert jetzt wieder 20 Minuten. Nein, nein, das habe ich diesmal. War es was mit Karamell? Auch lustig, aber das war es nicht. Mega lustig, aber das war es auch nicht. Was war es denn noch mal? So die Situation, wenn sich zwei Leute an der Ampel gegenüberstehen und es ist so, wer drückt und wer nicht? Sowas? Auch unfassbar, ich kann mich nicht zusammenreißen lustig. Aber ich denke, das war da das passt auch nicht so mit leute die caps vorne rum aufsetzen und die die hinten rum aufsetzen ich sterbe vor lachen über über das bisschen schweiss was sich immer in der cap sammelt was super ist nicht gegen meinen neuen style ich will dir helfen aber doch nicht so helfen es gibt verschiedene lawinen schneelawawinen, Erdlawinen, Gerölllawinen.
Auch unglaublich, mir fehlen die Worte, wie lustig Lawinen sind. Aber du bist nicht überzeugt. Aber es war nicht das Thema. Was war's denn? Es fällt mir nicht mehr ein, es ist auch egal. Folgende Idee, wir gehören ganz kurz ins Intro ein und dann hast du vielleicht auch von deinen Gag gefunden. Viel Spaß mit dem Intro von Markus. Ron Keating.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu diesem aktuellen, naja, je nachdem wann ihr es hört, zu der neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast suchen mit Stefan T.
Und von B.
Vielen Dank.
Warum gehen uns die Buchstaben aus, oder? Was ist jetzt los?
Ich bin ja bei Steuer doch wahnsinnig, oder? Das ist ja viel zu laut.
Nee, nee, du bist nur zu nah angegangen, weil du keinen Popschutz hast.
Sorry. Weil bei unserem gesamten Equipment, was insgesamt mehrere zehntausend Euro wert ist, wurden uns die Popschutze gestohlen. Richtig, ausgerechnet das, was am billigsten ist. Man hat die 300 Euro Sennheiser-Mikrofone hat man da gelassen, man hat sich für die Popschutze entschieden. Dummer Dieb, einfach sehr, sehr dummer Dieb. Ja, wie meine Theorie, Kupferdiebe ist Kupfer, wir leben nicht im Mittelalter. Da verstehe ich, dass man Kupfer sammelt, um es irgendwie dem Händler zu geben und sich dafür, weiß ich nicht, dann nachher um Med zu holen. Das sind alle meine Mittelalterbücher. Aber ich verstehe nicht, klaut euch ein Samsung. So einen großen, so einen UHD-Curved bei mir. Bei mir kann man leicht einbrechen, ganz leicht einbrechen. Hast du eine Menge Kupfer bei dir zu Hause? Könnte man bei dir sich nicht... Nee, aber eine Menge Fernseher, also eine Menge Fernseher. Ja, aber das ist gefährlich.
Fernseher sind ja gefährlich, weil da ist ja eine...
Kupfer.
Wie sagt man?
Im...
Unter...
Vakuum, da ist ein Vakuum drin. In dem Fernseher. Im Fernseher. Das heißt, wenn ich den Fernseher aufschlage, zieht es die Luft aus meinem Raum. Richtig, denn bist du im Fernsehen. Was? Ja. So komme ich ins Fernsehen. Im Fernsehen ist es total verrückt. Aber deswegen immer vorsichtig, bitte Leute, passt auf bei Fernsehern. Gerade so, ich bin wütend auf die GEZ und jetzt mache ich so ein provokantes GIF und haue mit dem Hammer auf die Fernsehscheibe. Wurden schon viele Leute das Antimateriel drin, da wird man reingezogen. Ja, das ist richtig gefährlich. Ganz kurze Frage, Stefan. Klinge ich so? Wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, w hier rumkommandierst, kurz bevor die Sendung losgeht, was du für ein Organisationsprecher bist, wie du den Zeitplan hier einhältst. Du hast nicht bestätigt. Ich bin nicht dein Hündchen. Du hast nicht bestätigt. Seit wann muss ich denn bestätigen? Du musst bestätigen. Das ist die Regel, man bestätigt. Wer bin ich denn? Ich bin nicht dein Hündchen. Ich habe gesagt, hast du um acht Uhr Zeit, du hast gesagt, ja, ich habe es verschieben müssen leider, habe ich auf zwanzig und dreissig verschoben, dann hast du gesagt, okay, du hast bestätigt, das hast du gut gemacht, du hast bestätigt, dann habe ich gesagt, kannst du auch schon um zwanzig und fünfzehn, darauf keine Reaktion. Stefan. Mache ich mir dann also irgendwie, mache ich mir dann Stress, um eher da zu sein?
Aus, aus!
Ich bin nicht dein Hündchen, Stefan.
Meine Theorie ist folgende, man muss dann nicht bestätigen, wenn man glaubhaft davon ausgehen kann, dass der andere die Nachricht gelesen hat, wenn schon ein schnell getakteter Dialog davor stattgefunden hat. Weil dann kannst du davon ausgehen, weisst du, wenn ich dir schreibe und da kommt nichts, dann kann ich nicht davon ausgehen, dass du angekommen bist. Ich muss ganz kurz darüber lachen.
Aktion, Reaktion, Aktion, Reaktion, Aktion.
Dann kann ich davon ausgehen, dass die Aktion auch angekommen ist bei dir, auch wenn die Reaktion ausbleibt. Also, wenn bei dir, wenn du was liest, heißt das gar nichts. Selbst wenn du, streng genommen, selbst wenn du bestätigst, heißt das gar nichts. Ich saß schon mal zwei Tage und zwei morgenden und zwei Ernten saß ich hier und habe auf dich gewartet, bis du endlich kommst, wo du angewackelt kommst mit deinem Rucksack und deinem Mikrofon. Ich weiß, wenn du bestätigst, in der Regel bist du da, aber wenn keine Bestätigung kommt, denke ich mir, ja, vielleicht auch nicht. Aber es ist auch nicht schlimm, ich habe mich ja beeilt. Vor der Sendung machst du hier den Orga-Görigen und dann
während der Sendung fällst du mir noch den Rücken.
Ich muss echt sagen,
ich glaube, ich bin in diesem Alter, ich hatte Geburtstag
und ich bin in diesem Alter. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Danke.
Dankeschön,
weil privat kam ja gar nichts.
Deswegen
dadurch spreche ich es nochmal an.
Ja, Happy Birthday.
Das ist jetzt offiziell.
Du musst nicht singen. Happy Birthday to you. Schön. Ich wollte es nochmal ansprechen, weil da kam keine Nachricht an dem Tag. Du willst ganz viele positive Kommentare zu deiner Person entlocken, weil schon lang kein Lob mehr kam für Tietze. Da kam schon lang kein schönes Wort. Oh, schöner Sprechfluss, gute Intonation, da kam schon lang kein Lob mehr. Und jetzt willst du endlich mal ein bisschen was aus unserer Hörergräbfung zu rauspressen. Alles gut. Was mir noch aufgefallen ist, ich bin jetzt in diesem Alter, wo man Dinge anders macht. Zum Beispiel achtet man auf Organisation. Du bist 17. Ich wurde 17. Man braucht Bestätigung, zum Beispiel um auf Termine zu reagieren. Wenn du nicht bestätigst, kommt meinerseits gar nichts mehr zu. Aber woher soll ich das denn wissen, dass du unbedingt die Bestätigung brauchst? Nee, ich hätte Geburtstag. Nur weil du jetzt 14 geworden bist, heißt das nicht, dass plötzlich alle deine Regeln kennen, Stefan. Aber man fragt sich ja so ein bisschen, man fragt sich, das hast du mal irgendwann gesagt, wann ist der Tag, wo man seine Fingernägel schneiden muss? Also wann erreicht man gewisse, ein neues Level?
Weil das Leben läuft nicht wie in Leveln, es läuft geradlinig, aber irgendwann ist schlagartig ein neues Level erreicht. Und ich hatte so einen Moment vor zwei Wochen, ungefähr an meinem Geburtstag, am 5. August habe ich, wie du weißt, Geburtstag. Ja, und da war so ein Tag auch, es war der Tag, an dem ich angefangen habe, mir statt Schriftgröss, also man kann es ja bei Pages und bei Google Drive und in anderen Programmen kann man sich die Schriftgrösse anzeigen lassen. Und man ist immer auf 125 voreingestellt. Das war der Tag, wo ich auf 150 Prozent an sich gewechselt bin. Das ist das Alter. Man will sich nicht eingestehen, aber genau an diesem einen Tag vor zwei Wochen bin ich auf hundertfünfzig gestiegen. Hundertfünfzig waren mir zu klein. Ich sass vor dem Rechenabend, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, aber das sind diese Tage. Aber Comic Sans hast du gelassen. Naja, Comic Sans habe ich weiterhin gelassen. Da muss man, glaube ich, mindestens sechzehn werden, bis man da rauswächst. Ist immer noch hilarious. Sains, sagst du Sains? Sans. Sans. Sans. Sans. Sans. Manche französischen Worte im Alter, Comic-Sands. Comic. Aber tatsächlich ist Sicht ein interessantes Thema. Man sagt mir nach, ich könne nicht gut sehen, aber ich kann dazu nicht Stellung beziehen, weil ich weiss nicht, wie gut ich potenziell sehen könnte. Also selbst der bestsehendste Mensch könnte ja auch noch theoretisch besser sehen. Also man weiss nicht, was ist der Vergleich. Ihm fehlt die Referenz. Ja. Dem bestsehendsten Menschen fehlt die Referenz. Er kann einfach behaupten, er sieht sehr gut. Oder er rät gut. Ich glaube, der bestsehendste Mensch rät nur gut in Sehtests. Ja, das stimmt auch. Die Chance ist 1 zu 26. Und dann musst du halt wie oft raten? 16 Mal? Irgendeine Person da draußen fährt gerade mit 180 auf der Autobahn, die beim Sehtest einfach nur kosmisch Glück hatte, weil bei Tausenden von Menschen den Führer schon haben, einer muss es zufällig durchkriegen. Ist blind wie Maulwurf, hat aber eine Sehstärke von tausend Prozent. Hat achtzehn Finger, vier Füße und keine Augen und ballert über die A6. Vor allem früher hat man mir gesagt, ich habe eine Sehstärke von 120
Wo ich dann gesagt habe, Moment, aber ihr legt doch fest, also ihr legt ja die Skala fest. Eure Skala ist falsch. Ja, das sind ja die Skala von 1980, die Menschen werden ja immer besser. Und dann haben die gesagt, mehrere Leute haben 120%. Und dann haben die gesagt, das sind mehrere Beweise dafür, dass eure Skala falsch ist. Seitdem habe ich Hausverbot bei vielem Mann. Aber das hatirrt, einfach. 120 Prozent. Aber hast du auf beiden 120 oder auf einem 120 und auf einem 80? Mittlerweile habe ich 60 Prozent auf beiden, glaube ich, einfach nur. Aber wahrscheinlich noch weniger, weil jetzt habe ich die 150 Prozent erreicht. Aber jetzt ist alles auf meinem Bildschirm ein bisschen grösser. Genau so, glaube ich, kommt irgendwann der Tag, wo man Tastentöne wieder anmacht am Handy. Ja, das stimmt. Wo einem Leute um und herum egal werden. Wo man den Klingelton immer auf maximale Lautstärke hochballert, weil warum nicht? Warum nicht? Weil why not? Ich habe auch ein Betriebssystem neu installiert und da ist es jetzt auch so die Funktion, dass wenn du deinen Cursor wackelst, dann wird der riesengroß. Bei mir auch. Ich liebe das, ich liebe das so. Einfach weil es dir zeigt, du Depp, du Depp, du bist ein Trottel, einfach guck mal, guck mal, hier ist dein Cursor.
Aber er sagt, auch hier bin ich.
Ich weiss schon, wo mein Cursor ist, das weiss ich schon, danke.
Aber es ist einfach so, er sagt es dir nochmal einfach.
Ich glaube, wenn man hinter mir steht, den ganzen Tag und mir zuguckt, wie ich an meinem Rechner sitze, der hält mich für bescheuert.
Jetzt macht er schon wieder die Geste, er weiss, wo die Maus ist, er macht es schon wieder, weil wow, die Maus, der Cursor wird ein bisschen grösser und man sieht es nicht häufig so groß und schwarz, aber er wird schon wieder ein bisschen grösser und das macht er jetzt schon wieder, wirklich, du hast es vor fünf Minuten erst gemacht. Aber das ist auch die schlimmste, ich weiß nicht genau, ob das, nennt man das passiv-aggressiv oder da gibt es vielleicht auch irgendein, irgendwas
Plaining-Begriff, dass man
Leute wirklich fertig machen kann, indem man ihnen
bewusst Dinge sagt, die sie schon wissen.
Es ist so ähnlich wie Mansplaining, aber es ist
ein bisschen fieser einfach.
Also zum Beispiel, ich spiele ab und zu
Warcraft 3 auf Rocket Beans TV
und Leute geben mir manchmal Tipps, die
wirklich für so, also das ist wie wenn du Cristiano
Ronaldo sagst, du pass auf, wenn du deine Schuhe zubindest vorm Spiel, dann kannst du schneller laufen. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr sehen ja, was passiert. Und das ist wirklich immer das Schlimmste, wenn dir nach der 20. Folge jemandem sagt, übrigens, wenn du auf dieses farbige Symbol auf deinem Schreibtisch doppelt klickst, dann kannst du das Spiel starten. Und dann denken sie, ah, okay, dankeschön, das ist jetzt, das daran lag es ja jetzt. Es ist wirklich schlimm. Ja, das stimmt schon, das nervt einen. Also damit kann man wirklich Leute in Wahnsinn treiben. Und ich sehe schon genau hundert Trolle, die bei uns in die Kommentare schreiben, hey Leute, wenn ihr das Mikrofonkabel in den, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ich, Popschütze werden ganz gut, Popschütze werden wir voll. Na, nicht so schlecht, glaube ich. Wenn ihr etwas mehr Abstand vom Mikrofon nehmt, dann sind die Störgeräusche nicht so hoch. Oh, ist das so? Ist das so? Wisst ihr, könnt uns mal! Leute schon hassen, bevor sie überhaupt reagieren können, so Präventivschlag, einfach so Hate-Raketenschild. Das ist das Wichtigste. Ich habe letzte Woche ganz vergessen, was zu sagen. Ich habe nämlich ... Stimmt, du hast die gesamte Folge nichts gesagt. Ich habe vergessen zu sprechen. Danke nochmal für die Kommentare. Ich wusste irgendwas war ... Wenn du deinen Mund auf und zu machst und mit der Zunge Wellen, Audiowellen machst, dann kommt das auch bei uns an. Ich hab dich noch auf dem Kasten.
Weil ich hör auf mein, also ich hör mich nicht mehr.
Ich hab dich noch auf dem Harry hier.
Ich hab dich noch schön auf dem Ton, Harry hier.
Aber können wir ganz kurz pausieren und reinhören?
Ja sicher, aber ich hab dich hier auf dem Harry.
Ja, mach mal auf dem Harry kurz Pause.
Alles sicher auf dem Harry, du, kein Problem. Wir haben reingehört und man war diese erste Viertelstunde lustig. Aber du kannst ja jetzt durchscrollen. Fang lieber jetzt nochmal von vorne an, als euch den Rest anzuhören. Du willst durchscrollen, du hättest direkt ans Ende springen können, das ist schon klar. Nee, nee, ich wollte ja so sehen, wie es mit dem Ton ist. Ich habe nämlich vergessen zu erzählen, dass ich vorletzte Woche eine Saftkur gemacht habe. Ich habe gesagt,
ich mache drei Tage lang nichts ausser Säfte trinken. Also, ich werde ein bisschen philosophisch, okay? Mir ist aufgefallen, dass Hunger eine Lehre ist. Mit H oder mit E? Eine Lehre, L-E-E-R-E. Aber nicht nur eine Magenlehre, sondern eine Lehre im Leben. Ne, und zwar ist folgendermassen, also... Soll das alles auf dem Kalender oder nur der erste Teil oder... Ne, hier an die Wand. Auch das mit dem E-E-Wandtattoo, wie gesagt. Also einfach so ganz gross an die Wand, wenn das geht. Tssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssss nichts, sondern du isst drei Tage lang gar nichts. Du trinkst eine Säfte, aber du darfst so viel trinken, wie du willst, oder wie? Du darfst so viel Wasser trinken, wie du willst. Wow, wow, wow, wo bin ich denn hier, in Pandoria? Und dann kriegst du pro Tag sechs Säfte. Also alle zwei Stunden darfst du den Saft trinken. Und Mann, habe ich mich auf ungerade Zahlen gefreut, als ich um elf angefangen habe. Wo ist die fünfzehn, wo ist die dreizehn, gib mir die neunzehn. Also du darfst nicht so viel Saft trinken, wie du möchtest. Nicht so viel Saft trinken, du darfst sechs Säfte trinken und so viel Wasser trinken, wie du willst. Aber das sind ja nur zwölf Stunden des Tages, der Tag hat ja mehr. Ja, aber du bist ja nur zwölf Stunden des Tages wach. Zwölf Stunden schläft man da. Ich war um achtzehn im Bett, weil ich dachte, ich habe so viel Hunger. Ich habe so viel Hunger, ich habe jetzt alle sechs Säfte weggetrunken und dann wird endlich dunkel, damit ich einschlafen kann. Das war wirklich ganz schlimm. Und dann abends ist mir dann aufgefallen, holy shit, dass die Tageszeit, wo du dir was zu essen bestellen würdest, wo es kommen würde, wo du es dir vorbereitest, wo du vielleicht was selber kochst und du hast einfach nichts, du hast Zeit. Und ich wusste nicht, was ich mit dieser Zeit anfangen sollte. Das habe ich am nächsten Tag dann einer Kollegin erzählt, mit der ich nicht so viel zu tun habe. Und die hat gesagt, ja, das zeugt, also wenn man sich so sehr aufs Essen freut, zeugt das von einer gewissen Lehre. Ciao. Und dann ist sie gegangen. Und dann saß ich da, den Rest des Tages im Büro. Mit deinem Saft in der Hand. Mit meinem Saft in der Hand und dachte mir, ja, der Hand und dachte mir, das stimmt. Essen ist für mich ein Riesending. Und ich wusste das bis zum Zeitpunkt nicht, wie sehr ich mich auf Essen freue, wie toll es ist, abends sich was Schönes zu essen zu bestellen oder zu machen und wie man sich darauf dann freut. Und das sind einfach die zwei Stunden, die sich darum drehen, sind einfach wichtige zwei Stunden des Tages. Es ist auch einfach verpflichtungsfreie Zone so, du machst dir gerade was zu essen, du wartest auf das Essen. Und du belohnst dich auch. Du musst da nichts anderes machen. Du belohnst dich dann auch. Und es war so schrecklich, dann abends da zu sitzen mit dem Saft, mit diesem Mandelscheiß. Der letzte Saft des Tages ist das ein Mandelsalzgetränk. Oh Gott. Und ich dachte mir, das kann nicht sein und es schmeckt furchtbar. Aber hast du es durchgezogen? Ich habe es komplett durchgezogen. Also erstmal Respekt an der Stelle. Weil du musst es ja nicht, du bist ja weder todkrank noch übergewichtig oder so. Ich hätte am ersten Abend gesagt, scheiß drauf, ich bestelle mir jetzt eine Pizza Hawaii. So, weil du hast ja keinen wirklichen Anreiz. Also ist es dir wirklich so wichtig, dass du mal glänzt oder was auch immer das ist? Das Ding ist, du merkst dadurch vor allem, wie dein Körper funktioniert, dass dein Körper nämlich, weil Beispiel, wenn du ein Aquarium hast und die Fische sollen wieder bunt werden, gibst du den Futter, was sie wieder bunt macht. Aber es sind halt nur Fische, weißt du, es sind kleine Organismen, du durchschaust diese Organismen und du denkst, klar, dieses kleine Futterding ist ein Achtel von dem Fisch.
Fische sind ja nicht so groß. Klar werden die jetzt bunter. Aber du selber bist genau so ein Organismus. Was du aufnimmst, hat unmittelbaren Einfluss auf deinen Körper. Und ich war drei Tage lang so in Delirium, so halb bewusstlos. Also irgendwann wurdest du dann ein bisschen glücklicher wieder, weil du dein Körper sich daran gewöhnt hat, aber du warst so ein bisschen so dizzy die ganze Zeit und du wolltest viel sitzen und es war einfach unangenehm. Am dritten Tag bist du dann ein bisschen wacher wieder, aber es ist ganz kommentisch, du bist neben dir und du hast erstmal so ein, du checkst erstmal, was für einen Einfluss das auf dein Leben hat, das ist unglaublich. Aber was war jetzt letztlich der Effekt, als du dann das abgeschlossen hast? Du hast tatsächlich nicht mehr so viel Hunger. Also du kannst gut restarten. Ich habe nämlich angefangen, Scheiße in mich reinzufressen den ganzen Tag. Und daran gewöhnt jetzt der Körper ja auch. Das heißt, du machst es weiter, du bist in so einer Abwehrspirale. Und das bist du nicht, also da kannst du dich raus befreien, wenn du einfach diese Saftkur machst. Der Körper gewöhnt sich ja nach drei Tagen dann diese Säfte und freut sich dann, wenn du auch klar, wenn du wieder dann irgendwie was Vernünftiges isst, frühstückst vernünftig, aber dann hast du nicht mal so viel Hunger. Also es ist ein kompletter Restart, du kriegst auch einen neuen Namen, neue Adresse, nochmal von vorne, neue komplett. Ich habe mich wieder Stefan Tietze genannt, das war ein Zufall tatsächlich, ich habe quasi wieder meinen Namen gezogen. Aber ja, ich bin jetzt quasi ein neuer Mensch. Und hast du das über das Wochenende gemacht oder während du gearbeitet hast? Nee, während ich gearbeitet habe. Wow. Ja, ja, ja. Du konntest trotzdem noch die Kohle-Miene schürfen währenddessen. Das ging noch. Ja, ich konnte noch die Kohle-Miene schürfen. Tatsächlich, aber muss ich sagen, bin ich jetzt schon wieder, also ich könnte jetzt schon wieder eine Saftkugel brauchen, weil ich jetzt schon wieder angefangen habe, den Quatsch zu essen, den, den ich vorher auch gesagt habe. Also ich denke es mal, wenn ich das durchziehen würde, und ich würde es nicht durchziehen, aber ich würde es den Rest meines Lebens als Entschuldigung für jedes Stück Sahnetorte nehmen, das ich sehe. So, Sahnetorte, naja, ich habe ja mal einen Glänz gemacht. Also mal vor acht Jahren fast diese Saftkur durchgehalten. Das los ist ja kein Problem. Vier Kilo Marzipan, naja gut, ich habe ja davor mal einen Glänz gemacht, schieb mir das rein. Ja, aber genau, es ist super spannend, mach das mal. Auf gar keinen Fall. Es kostet 99 Euro, alles was ich mache, was ich ausprobiere, kostet 99 Euro. Also das ist so ein spezielles Angebot, wo du alle Säfte zugeschickt bekommst. Wo du alle Säfte in so einer tollen Box und ich würde es doch mal wegen der Box machen, die war so Bambus mässig, das war ganz toll, also die Box war ein Highlight. Das Highlight man da vorhin hat drei Tage auf jeden Fall.
Aus Verzweiflung hast du versucht, die Box zu essen. Ja, ja, war lecker auch. Also diese Kühl-Dinger. Danach waren wir dann schlecht, aber diese Kühl-Akkus, die waren auch gut. Besser als der Mandel-Drink, holy shit. Aber wie gesagt, mach das mal interessante Erfahrung. Wir werden nicht bezahlt oder sowas, aber das ist schon interessant. Ich habe das gerne gemacht. Ich habe letztens gehört, dass wenn du dich allein von Hasen ernährst, verhungerst du, weil du wendest mehr Energie zur Hasenjagd auf, als Hasen dir letztlich Energie geben. Okay. Okay, das heißt, Vasen haben die beste Verteidigung der Welt, weil sie nicht gegessen werden können, weil alle Tiere, die sie essen, werden sterben, weil sie so schwer zu fangen sind, dass es sich nicht lohnt. Also du musst ja gar nicht irgendwie einen Giftstachel haben, sondern du musst den Jäger nur so viel Energie kosten, dass er sagt, es lohnt sich nicht. Weil auch so ein Jaguar merkt irgendwann, Leute, Seitenstechen. Gib mir mal einen Moment. Arm hoch. Ey, lass uns wieder irgendwie so einen scheiß Maulwurf oder so. Seitenstechen. Alter. So ein Jaguar hat viel Seite. Wenn der mal Seitenstechen hat, muss der direkt in den OP. Aber ist wirklich, also es gibt, ich glaube auch Sellerie, es kostet mehr Energie zu kauen und zu essen, als es tatsächlich die Energie liefert. Oh, der Selleriedrink, Flashbacks, puh, das war auch hart. Ja, aber Selleriedrink ist eine gute Idee, weil du musst nicht kauen. Das heißt, du hast noch einen Energieplus am Ende. Ja, man muss sagen, bei Säften, wenn du Säfte zu dir nimmst, verbrauchst du damit keine Energie, du kriegst aber auch sehr wenig zurück, das ist der Nachteil.
Aber musst du nicht irgendwie, also ich verstehe überhaupt sowieso nicht, wie Hunger funktioniert genau, wann der Körper sagt, man hat keinen Hunger mehr, weil erst dachte ich einfach, wenn der Magen voll ist, also reines Volumen, aber es ist ja schon so, dass wenn du zum Beispiel so dieses super krasse Müsli isst, so dieses heavy crunch, super dichte Müsli, da reicht dir oft schon eine halbe Schüssel und du bist satt.
Also es kann ja dann nicht rein nach Volumen gehen, weil das hat ja, wenn du jetzt das gleiche Volumen Apfel essen würdest, wärst du nicht satt. Also der Körper muss schon das prüfen am Eingang.
Aber wie ist es bei Säften?
Weil checkt der Körper sofort, ah, das ist was anderes als Wasser?
Oder wirst du, wenn du nicht kaust und nicht geschluckst und so,
wird man dann überhaupt satt?
Ja, also an Tag eins und zwei nicht.
An Tag drei hast du dann irgendwann so ein Sättigkeitsgefühl schon mal.
Das ist schon hart.
Also vor allem, ich finde es auch immer schlimm,
ins Bett zu gehen und einen leeren Magen zu haben. Ja. Und du hast auch keinen Stuhlgang halt. Das ist schon hart. Also vor allem, ich finde es auch immer schlimm, ins Bett zu gehen und einen leeren Magen zu haben. Und du hast auch keinen Stuhlgang halt. Das ist ganz geil. Du kannst danach an Tag vier deine Stuhlgangzeit, deine Arbeitszeiten anpassen. Ah, du kannst neue Resetten wieder. Du kannst Resetten. Und da war ich total auf der Suche nach, nach meinem Maledivenurlaub war ich in einem komischen Limbo, in einem Stuhlgang-Limbo. Das war gefährlich. Die Zeit war gefährlich, es lief in die Arbeitszeit. Das mir noch nie in meinem Leben passiert. Aber ist das nicht gut, dann kannst du dir schön eine Pause rausholen. Aber du willst doch nicht auf der Arbeit Stuhlgang haben. Ja, aber schön irgendwie auf dem Klo Tinder noch ein bisschen, zehn Minuten Arbeitszeit rausholen. Ich habe das sehr unangenehm gefunden und bin jetzt froh, meine 21 Uhr wieder zu haben. Aber guck mal, jetzt kannst du nicht mehr essen, aber dafür nimmst du jetzt eine Stunde Zeit, ganz ausgiebig. Was hast du, das war toll. Darf ich mal, sehr intime Frage, aber darf ich mal nach deiner Klolektüre fragen? Keine, Handy in der Hand. Nichts liegt bei dir schön auf dem Handy in der Hand oder mittlerweile lächerlich, aber man ist dann so, also du kannst dich ja komplett umgeben mit Entertainment. Das heißt, manchmal wenn ich eine Serie auf meinem Laptop gucke laufe ich mit dem Laptop und der Serie an, aufs Klo stelle den auf meine Badewanne vor meinem Klo und nehme den dann am Ende wieder mit, weil ich die nicht unterbrechen will, weil ich meine Zeit optimieren will, also das ist meine Klolektüre, die Serie, die ich gerade gucke oder mein Handy.
Okay, also keine, also gut, du hast vielleicht nicht so viele Gäste, aber braucht man, wenn man Gäste hat, dann braucht man Klolektüre oder was? Gehört das zum guten Ton? Ach so, ich denke dabei echt nicht an meine Gäste. Warum müssen Häuser an Gäste denken? Nicht das Haus, du, also ich dachte jetzt eher an dich selbst, nicht an das. Na gut, aber ich bin ja das ... Also, warum musst du an deine Gäste denken? Also warum brauchen die ... Weil die haben doch auch ... Niemand liest doch bei sich zu Hause Klolektüre. Man liest doch nur als Gast Klolektüre. Also ich habe mal von jemandem gehört, dass diese Person es als sehr gastfreundlich empfindet, wenn eine ordentliche Klo-Lektüre vorliegt. So ein schönes,
lustiges Taschenbuch. Kreuzwortrösel.
So halb ausgefüllt,
ohne Stift. Und man weiss die Antwort,
aber man kann sie nicht reinschreiben.
So ein Kreuzwortrösel finde ich immer ganz gut.
Idee, ein ausgefülltes
für ein Date. Wenn du,
zum ersten Mal kommt dann
deine Date-Partnerin, kommt mit dir nach Hause.
Geht erstmal kacken direkt. So, geht erstmal schön aufs Klo, naja, frisch machen dir nach Hause. Geht erst mal kacken direkt.
So, geht erst mal schön aufs Klo, na ja, frisch machen, okay, frisch machen, nicht kacken. Ja. Und dann kriegt die, und dann hast du als Klolektüre natürlich ein Kreuzworträtsel, was perfekt ausgefüllt ist, aber so ein schweres. Und das legst du da hin und sie geht aufs Toilette, sieht, holy shit. Ja, damit Tinderinchen83 denkt, wow, der ist ja richtig gebildet, der kann das die bunte Kreuzworträtsel auf drei Chilischoten in Schwierigkeitsgrad. Wow, er weist die Hauptstadt von Belgien, toll, mega. Nee, aber so ein richtig schweres, wo man, wenn man etwas liest, denkt, was? Ich kenne nicht mal das echt ein zweites Wort für und nicht mal das Wort, für das man ein Wort finden soll, kennt man. Ach, ich dachte jetzt, du machst so eine romantische Aktion, dass du schon das Kreuzworträtsel ausgefüllt hast, aber manipuliert so. Schönste Frau der Welt, Laura. Ach so. Und dann heißt sie Laura. Ja, dann denkt sie, ich bin romantisch, aber sehr dumm. Das stimmt. Ja, mal gucken. Aber man sehr viel mit Klo-Lektüre die Gäste manipulieren, das stimmt schon. Vielleicht soll ich es mal einführen. Hast du Klo-Lektüre? Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne? Du bist auch in einer WG. Du wohnst in vielen WGs. Ja, das stimmt, ne, WG nicht. WG nicht. Ja, aber tatsächlich mal, das habe ich schon mal erzählt, glaube ich, dass ich mal so einen Taschenrechner hatte, wo man Sachen eingeben konnte und speichern konnte. Zahlen?
Nee, auch Text. Also ein bisschen krasser Taschenrechner. Computer, glaube ich, würde man heute sagen. Aber ganz früh, also als ich irgendwie acht war oder so, so einer von diesen mit so einem Mini-Display. Und da konnte man Textnachrichten speichern und sogar mit Passwort versehen. Zu viele Funktionen für ein Gerät, was so wenig benutzt, um, keine Ahnung, die Einkaufsliste. Ja, aber als ich das rausgefunden habe, habe ich da eingespeichert, in wen ich verliebt war zu der Zeit. Weil ich dachte, sollte ich das jemals vergessen? Esel, 5373. Ja, I love Esel. Und dann finden das die Eltern und sagen, wir müssen miteinander reden. Wer ist Esel? Ich kann so eine schöne, so wie Hazel, Esel? Ja. Esel Brugger? Meinst du, die wurde gemobbt als Esel? Als Esel Brugger, Esel? Was meinst du? Was meinst du, Esel? Ja, vielleicht reissen wir jetzt alte Wunden auf, falls sie natürlich nicht zuhört. Ja, ja, da muss man aufpassen. Lustiger Witz, 5373, also hat mich wirklich durch zwei Klassen gebracht, humoristisch, wo ich dachte, das kann nicht sein. An alle Schüler da draußen, die Top 40 lustige Spielereien mit dem Taschenrechner, Platz 40. Also wenn man Doppelpunkt und dann Klammer zu macht, das ist Smiley. Platz 39, ich nenne es die Überquerung des Reins. Und zwar, was man macht, ist, man füllt fünf Stellen aus mit einem O, äh mit einem Null zum Beispiel, fünf Nullen und dann zwei Spieler. Und einer drückt ganz schnell die Null, so oft er kann, und der andere drückt ganz schnell löschen, so dass immer wieder gelöscht und die neue Null. Der dritte Mitspieler haut euch die ganze Zeit in die Fresse, weil ihr scheisse Nerds seid. Ja, und dann kann man so einen Kampf machen, wer schneller drücken kann, und bei wem dann die Null ankommt, der hat dann verloren, und wenn die Null dann bei einem ist, glaube ich, versteht man. Platz Nummer achtunddreißig. Hätte ich mich da vorbereiten sollen? Esel, Esel, Esel.
Okay, wenn ihr 5, 3, 7, 3 eingebt, sieht es erst wie Zahlen aus. Oh, was, 5, 3, 7, 9? Und dann dreht es mal um. Und dann habt ihr den Lacher auf eurer Seite. Platz Nummer 37, gebt mal ein, acht eins, acht eins, acht eins, acht eins, Adolf Hitler, Adolf Hitler, ne warte, acht eins, acht eins, acht, neun mal insgesamt, also neun Ziffern. Ja, ja. Oder zehn. Platz Nummer 36. Ne, und dann macht einfach so oft acht eins, bis das Display voll ist und dann geteilt durch neun, geteilt durch neun, geteilt durch neun und dann Abroffelgarantie. Hundertprozentig. Was ist die? Ja, das kannst du heute auch mal ausprobieren. 69 oder was ist die? Nee, das kannst du heute auch mal ausprobieren. Okay, Platz Nummer zwei. Ja, wir haben ein bisschen vorgespult. Geht eine acht ein, dann gleicher Zeichen, beliebig viele Gleichheitszeiten und dann ein, entweder welche Klasse noch, der kann ein D machen, ansonsten macht ihr die Klassiker eine drei und dann habt ihr einen Penis, je nachdem in eure gewünschten Länge, Platz Nummer zwei.
Und Platz Nummer eins, eins schon.
Versuchen, ob er 99 hoch 99 rechnen kann oder ob da Error kommt.
Platz Nummer eins.
Mein Platz Nummer eins.
Nehmt den Taschenrechner, macht euer Fenster auf und werft ihn auf dem Fenster.
Und dann fangt was mit eurem Leben an, was anders ist als Taschenrechner Games.
Das waren die Top 35.
Dafür haben wir extra einen Jingle komponiert oder was? Das machen wir dann nie wieder. Dafür hat das Prager Sinfonieorchester einen Jingle eingespielt. Wirklich? Ich war in Frankreich. Ich habe die letzten Tage in Frankreich. Ich war aber das Wochenende unterwegs. Kleiner Kurzurlaub, kleiner Trip in Frankreich zu unseren guten Freunden. Zwei Weltkriege, sorry! Und jetzt aber ist alles gut zwischen uns, also man hat sich, man beäugt sich ein bisschen vorsichtig auf der Strasse. Aber du siehst schon ein bisschen französisch aus. Ja, ja, aber ansonsten ist alles gut. Weil man in Deutschland Kappe geht und diese Brille, wo man nicht durchgucken kann, die man bei Fußballwehrmacht hat. Wo man alles in schwarz-rot-golz und denkt, es ist ständig Sonnenuntergang eigentlich. Eine schöne Flagge. Eine schöne Flagge. Und es war schön und wir waren unterwegs, aber es ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig in einem Land unterwegs sein, dessen Sprache man nicht spricht oder nicht gut spricht. Es ist immer unangenehm, vor allem es ist in den Momenten unangenehm, wenn man nicht erklären kann, dass man die Sprache nicht spricht. Und wenn man sehr gut die einfachen Wörter wie Ja, Nein spricht. Genau. Und dann sprichst du so gut aus, dass sie sich vollbrabbeln mit Französisch. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es am lokalen Dialekt lag, wo ich war, oder ob das generell eine französische Art ist, aber dass man das We eher We spricht. We. Das wird scharf und gesprochen. Und deswegen, wenn man sich das aneignet, glaube ich, fallen recht viele Menschen darauf rein, wenn jemand mit ihr Reden so. Also man muss auch so leicht auf seinen Bauch drücken. Dann kommt das auch raus. Diese Tiere, die man kennt bei Toys-Arts, wenn man mal gegen so ein Regal läuft. Weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh, weh. Weh, weh, weh. Hey, ja, ja. Und Enten sind auch generell französisch. Weh. Und also das ist auf jeden Fall gut. Und das No? Habe ich nie gesagt. Ich war ein sehr positiver Ausflug. Das ist nie No. Wenn du immer weh und nie no sagst, dann kommst du schon mal in doofe Situationen. Naja, man kommt auch wieder Hut raus. Wollen sie Wollen Sie gehen? Und du bist weg. Und schwierig sind aber Situationen, in denen man nicht rüberbringen kann, dass man sich nicht versteht. Wie zum Beispiel, wenn dir im Zug das Ticket ... Je ne parle pas, Frosse. Ja, aber das kannst du dir nicht mal was sagen, wenn jemand dich anspricht. Also wenn jemand das Ticket kontrolliert, dann hältst du ihm einfach das Ticket hin und dann musst du nichts sagen. Dann sagt er Merci und du sagst Weh, Weh und dann hat sich
Weh und vor allem bei mir war die Situation, da kam der Kontrolleur
und hat bei mir kontrolliert und während er mein Ticket in der Hand hatte,
hat er relativ heftig geniesst.
Und ich schaue ihn an,
augenweit aufgerissen und er guckt mich an
und ich weiß nicht, was Gesundheit auf Französisch heißt.
Ja.
Und ich gucke ihn an und es sind so Sekunden der Stille, die umso länger werden, weil man, also man hat das so konditioniert, sein gesamtes Leben lang, dass jemand niest, eins, zwei, Gesundheit, danke, und ich schaue ihn an, wirklich Hilfe suchen, und nichts kommt und ich sage einfach nichts und er gibt mir das Ticket wieder und geht und er dachte sich einfach, was ein Arschloch, aber ich wusste einfach nicht, was ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, excusez-moi monsieur, je ne parle français, je suis allemande, je ne parle de, de gesundheitliche, de bless you, weiss einfach nicht und das sind die unangenehmsten Momente, wenn du irgendwie im Hotel bist und die einfach sagt, je suis allmonde, je ne comprends pas, dann weiss jeder, was los ist und dann spricht er Englisch mit dir. Aber solche Situationen sind schwierig. Und so geht es mir beim doch im Englischen, beim doch. Doch, ah, okay. Es rutscht mir so oft rein. Dass du doch sagst, oder was? Ja, auch wenn man irgendwann eine Woche da ist und so
angesprochen, ja, ist so ein deutsches Wort,
sondern man hat recht, ja,
es ist das Gegenteil von dem, was du sagst
und ich will nur ein Wort dafür benutzen,
weil es kommt so häufig vor, wir brauchen ein Wort
dafür, wir widersprechen uns alle
so häufig, aber positiv,
wir widersprechen uns positiv, wir brauchen ein Wort,
mit dem wir auf irrationale Weise
auf unserem falschen Punkt beharren können, hat jemand eine Idee? Doch, das gibt es doch schon. Nee, doch. Okay. Okay. Stimmt. Okay, Frederik, noch ein Vorschlag. Nee, doch ist schon super, aber gibt es im Englischen nicht. Und da fällt man manchmal rein, deswegen sage ich manchmal doch. Und dann sorgt es immer für Fragezeichen im Gesicht. Das stimmt, das habe ja auch schon mal erzählt, aber ich, bei mir kam es eine komische Situation in Norwegen, wo ich dann irgendwann so in diesem Hi drin war, Hi, so hat man sich ja begrüsst, Hi, also Hallo. Und dann bin ich dann am Flughafen in Norwegen gewesen und habe dann irgendwie im Duty-Free-Shop irgendwas gekauft und habe gesagt, Hi, und wurde dann bezahlen Und es war so ein überzeugendes, genailtes Hi, dass sie mich angesprochen hat in Norwegisch. Und ich sage, so sorry, I can't speak Norwegian. Man macht sich halt immer drüber lustig, über Touristen, vor allem deutsche Touristen, die dann irgendwie so, ja, bonjour, je suis, un vino, roso. Aber ich glaube, das ist eigentlich eine sinnvolle Strategie, dem Gegenüber sofort zu signalisieren, dass man sich Mühe gibt, aber einfach kein Franzose ist, definitiv nicht, so dass der Gegenüber viel besser reagieren kann, weil wenn du da jetzt die halt so zwei, drei Sätze zurechtlegst und vielleicht so ein bisschen Ohr für Sprachen hast und das rüberbringen kannst, dann wird es zu viel mehr Verwirrung, weil der andere erst realisieren muss, ah, der ist nicht komplett bescheuert, sondern
der spricht einfach die Sprache nicht.
Ich habe jetzt angefangen, Japanisch zu lernen.
Und
tatsächlich, und diese Sprach-App,
die macht vieles richtig.
Tatsächlich ist es total sinnvoll.
Sorry, warum gerade Japanisch?
Was hat der Gedanke?
Du bist ja überhaupt kein Anime
oder Manga-Fan oder irgendwas. Du hast keine Hobbys in Richtung Japan. Ich habe keinen Bezug zu dem Land, zur Kultur, Sushi manchmal. Also warum Japan? Ich habe keine Ahnung, komplett irrational. Ich habe so viel Stress auf der Arbeit mittlerweile und ich komme jeden Abend um 22 Uhr nach Hause und das ist meine Art, mich zu entspannen neuerdings. Es kam aus dem Nichts. Aus dem Nichts habe ich angefangen, Japanisch lernen zu wollen. Und ich habe auch wirklich Spaß daran. Ich kann mich damit auch so vom Schlafen gehen einfach, kurz mal Japanisch ballern. Und dann habe ich, aber es ist schwierig, weil du erstmal brauchst so ewig, bis du ein Muster erkennst überhaupt. Ja, also die Zeichen, lernst du auch die Zeichen? Ich lerne auch die Zeichen, die Sprachen, es gibt ja verschiedene Zeichenspr ist ja super schwer ist super schwer und du brauchst ewig bis du überhaupt mal ein muster erkennst bis aus dem g und k und da siehst du an den an den es ist das gleiche zeichen aber mit verschiedenen symbolen daneben und du erkennst ah und es alle g's werden dann zum k wenn das und da ist oder alle bs werden zum p wenn das und da ist wenn der punkt ist Also in einem Kreis. Und das checkst du dann so nach und, wenn das und da ist. Oder alle Bs werden zum P, wenn das und da ist, wenn ein Punkt ist, also ein Kreis.
Und das checkst du dann so nach und nach. Das ist super schwierig. Und da ist es auch so, dass die Sprachapp dir, die spricht halt Dinge vor. Zum Beispiel Guten Morgen heißt Ohio. So, aber jetzt ist da immer diese Frau, die das Wort immer Ohio ausspricht. Guten Morgen. Das heisst, wenn ich sage, Ohio, checken das Leute oder muss Ohio ausgesprochen werden. Also eigne ich mir dann dieses Ohio an und entweder halten die Leute mich für bescheuert, weil die... Oder es ist perfekt, du naisst es. Oder es ist perfekt. Aber dann habe ich mir... Das ist der neue Kaiser einfach. Ja, genau. Und dann habe ich mir so ein paar Videos angeschaut, einfach weil ich wissen wollte, wie das andere Leute aussprechen, ob das an der Sprecherin liegt, weil die einfach ein bisschen die ganze Wörter reingehauen hat. Aber alle sagen Ohio. Also es fließt so aus. So tief, hoch, tief. Ohio. Ja, ja, genau. Das ist anscheinend die Betonung, aber das ist ja eine ganz irrationale, also dem deutschen Ohr klingt es einfach wie ein Schrei, wie falsch betont, einfach sofort.
Obwohl man ja, es ist ja kein deutsches Wort,
aber man, die deutsche... Es ist sogar ein englisches
Wort, streng genommen. Aber das
deutsche Ohr sagt einfach, nee, nee, nee,
kein Wort, aber ich glaube,
so muss man sagen, also ich werde auf jeden Fall
durch die Hotels in Japan
laufen und Ohayo!
Ohayo! Ohayo!
Weil die werden sagen, das ist racist.
Ja, das ist rassistisch Stefan-san, rassistisch
rassistisch-san.
Nee, Stefan-san, Tietze-san wäre richtig.
Mister, Mister Tietze. Ach so.
Ja, aber das ist interessant.
Ich werde euch mal up to date halten.
Ich bin tatsächlich irgendwann nicht über ein Level.
Die App ist mega, Duolingo,
mega App, weil die,
du kannst dann erst weiter, also wenn du zu schlecht bist für ein Level, dann sagt es, nee, nee, nee, für dich ist vorbei jetzt, damit du einfach nicht zu viel machst. Damit du nicht hängen bleibst irgendwo. Damit du nicht hängen bleibst. Ich bin trotzdem hängen geblieben bei Food1. Food1 hat mir irgendwann das Gedick gebrochen. Ja. Wenn ich das so bitte, was habt ihr da gesagt? Und dann auch immer, es ist auch schwierig, weil dann, du musst das Handy immer auf laut haben, weil du hörst, es spricht dir ja Dinge vor. Ja, ja. Naja, aber es macht jedenfalls sehr viel Spaß und ich werde euch abzudate halten, ob ich da irgendwelche Sachen schon sagen kann.
Bislang bleibt es bei A.O. Heide.
Also ich glaube, eine andere Sprache im Ton zu lernen geht, aber auch noch diese Schrift lesen können, das ist ja schon was ganz anderes.
Du hast jetzt 14 Jahre deines Lebens diese klassische Schrift gelesen und da ist eine ganz andere, das ist schon verrückt. Ja ich glaube, man kriegt das trotzdem hin irgendwie. Man kriegt das hin. So richtig fliessend den Text lesen. Holy shit, also da bin ich noch sehr weit von entfernt. Also ich kann zumindest diese eine Schrift kann ich schon ganz gut lesen, da kenne ich auch mittlerweile alle Symbole für. Aber dann fängt das dann so Kanji und dann kommen auch so ein bisschen chinesische Schriftzeichen rein. Und dann wird es einfach nur kontraintuitiv. Weil dann ist Sonne irgendwie dann so drei superkomplexe Schriftzeichen. Also das macht keinen Sinn. Also es macht einfach keinen Sinn, so jemals ein Wort zu beschreiben. Meinetwegen, wenn Sonne ein Schriftzeichen ist, was komplex ist meinetwegen, dann verstehe ich das. Und dann Sonnenbrand und dann zwei Zeichen. Genau, zum Beispiel. Oder halt so einen Brand draufmalen auf das Zeichen. Keine Ahnung. Aber das verstehe ich noch. Aber weil ihr halt unsere sechs Buchstaben, fünf, fünf Buchstaben getauscht habt gegen ein Symbol. Das verstehe ich dann. Aber sobald ein Symbol,
ein Wort, halt irgendwie drei
superkomplexe Symbole hast, die ewig dukt, musst du
bestimmt, weiss ich nicht, da schreibst du eine Viertelstunde dran
an diesem Satz.
Und es ist dann einfach nur Sonne, das verstehe ich dann nicht.
Da muss ich nochmal gucken.
Ich glaube, das haben wir schon mal gefragt, aber haben die dann auch
eine Schreibschrift oder so?
Oder gibt es dann auch verschiedene Arten zu schreiben?
Verschiedene Fonts, ja.
Aber das habe ich mittlerweile schon gecheckt, zumindest in der sehr einfachen japanischen Schriftart, wo ich da, wo die man zuerst lernt, wo ich mittlerweile auch fast alle Symbole kann, die, da checke ich mittlerweile andere Schriftarten auch. Das ist, glaube ich, einfach nur, wenn du dich daran gewöhnst. Aber an diesen komplexen Schriftarten kann ich mir fast nicht vorstellen, das sind ja grossartig, krasse neue Fonds. Graffiti, dass man da mal sowas taggt? Taggt? Das ist schwierig. Man braucht so ganz große Sachen. Also auf jeden Fall, ich war in Frankreich, Airbnb, und was ich nicht wusste, war, dass der Airbnb-Besitzer auch in der Wohnung schläft. Das ist immer so, das geht manchmal unter in der Bestellung. Wir waren zu dritt und der hat auch immer darauf bestanden, jeden Morgen mit uns zu frühstücken. Und das ist ja die unangenehmste Situation der Welt, weil wir alle drei sprechen kein gutes Französisch, eher kein Deutsch. Wir wollen uns nicht auf Deutsch unterhalten, weil das unhöflich wäre ihm gegenüber. Und dann sitzt man halt einfach da und dann kriegt man halt so raus, ah, wie war die Fahrt? Très bien, wo geht ihr heute noch hin? Très bien. En la vie de, je ne comprends pas. Und dann verläuft es sich halt so und das Schlimmste. Dann hat man so eine grosse Pfeife in der Hand und nimmt dann die grössere Pfeife. Genau, man hat so eine Pistole und dann kommen Leute und dann knallen die die Juden unter einem ab. Und das Schlimmste ist ja, also der hat das wahrscheinlich gemacht, einfach aus Gastfreundschaft, weil er dachte, das gehört sich so, vielleicht ist es auch französische Kultur oder gute Bewertungen abstauben oder so, keine Ahnung. Aber es war unendlich quälend, sich da durchzuquälen durch diese Morgen und das Schlimmste, was es ja gibt und das ist ja teuflisch beim Frühstück, sind ja
Heissgetränke, weil also wenn das so ein, keine Ahnung, so ein Bierchen nebenbei ist, das kannst
du zur Not wegechsen, aber dann vor allem, vor allem die anderen haben Kaffee getrunken, ich habe
immer Tee bekommen, habe ich so ein kochend heißes Wasser und den Teebeutel und dann musst du, also ich hätte ja wirklich am liebsten den einmal so reingedippt und Echsen und dann einfach mit Schmerz verzerrtem Gesicht aus dem Haus gehen, so Nun, Nusom, ach, drehst du dich um, ist so ein Loch in deinem Körper. Nus, Nusalon, ach, ich habe doch keine Ahnung, man geht einfach. Und das ist so quärend, weil du musst dann immer den Teebeutel erst ewig lang. Und dann, oh Gott, und dann kannst du das nicht, und dann schaut man sich so um, treffen sich die Blicke und man hat einfach nichts zu sagen. Der Tee ist ein Socializing-Getränk. Und das halt drei fucking morgen lang und ich hatte wirklich Albträume, ich wollte nicht mehr ins Bett gehen. Ich wollte nicht ins Bett gehen, weil ich hatte so Angst vor diesem Frühstück und vor allem,
man kann den auch nicht absagen, man sagt dann,
wir müssen früh morgens los und dann so,
ein Kaffee, ein Te, ein Bruder,
ich spreche eure Sprache.
Je ne compre pas, je ne compre pas,
und du kommst nicht raus. Es war sehr, sehr heftig. Das glaube ich. Also, Francois, falls du zuhörst, es tut mir leid, es tut mir leid, aber ich, das ist auch die Frage, gibt man da jetzt eine schlechte Bewertung? Nein, oder man kann doch da keine schlechte Bewertung geben für den aufdringlichen Gastgeber. Nee, super, also alles war toll für Leute, die super aufdringliche Gastgeber mögen, die mit einem, die darauf bestehen, mit einem zu frühstücken, auch wenn man kein Wort der Sprache spricht und jemand der Juden im Keller hat.
Ja, und dann kommt er vor allem mit so einer Flasche Apfelsaft, selbst gepressten Apfelsaft, denke ich. Er hat so auf seinen Apfelbaum gezeigt und dann auf die Flasche, da gehe ich davon aus. Und der Apfelbaum auf sich gezeigt, mehr als mich, und Habe ich auf ihn gezeigt und die Flasche hat gesagt, ich habe damit nichts zu tun. Dann habe ich ihn getrunken und ganz verwirrend und er hat gesagt, wie viele Äpfel das gebraucht hat und wir haben alle was anderes verstanden. Ich habe 20 Kilo verstanden, der andere hat 20 Äpfel verstanden, der andere hat 20 Tonnen Äpfel verstanden. Der andere hat scharfe Blau-Wolken verstanden. Man weiss es einfach nicht. Aber das ist dann auch so fies, dann gibt dir das selbstgemachte Apfelsaft und du willst einfach nur das einfach wegechsen. Und vor allem, oh, das ist auch noch gut, da hat er uns jeden Morgen so eine Art Smoothie gemacht. auch wirklich massivste Sprachbarriere, er gibt uns so ein kleines Glas oranges Zeug, wo aber so Kiwi-Kerne drin sind unten, also ein Mischgetränk, so, man trinkt das und dann fragt er einen, ah, schmeckt es gut, ja, was soll man da sagen, und dann, und dann, Gehaltvolles Gespr, durch viel gestikulieren, haben wir verstanden, dass er möchte, dass wir raten, was in diesem Getränk drin ist. So. Uns fehlt wirklich jegliches Vokabular, Dinge wie Orange, Grapefruit, Maranka, keine Chance. Dann bist du nämlich in der Lektion drin, dann bist du in der Lektion Früchte, in der dritten Lektion und du hast einfach kein Vokabular. Ohio, nein! Und irgendwann zählt er auf und zählt auch so nonchalant einfach auf, dass da auch Schnaps mit drin ist irgendwie und wir haben das jeden Morgen getrunken, aber es ist halt Frankreich, weißt du? C'est la France, C'est le vie, ja, wir haben schon zwei Weltkriege verloren, was soll jetzt noch passieren? Ja, da ich gefragt, warum ist euer Leben besser? Warum sind wir jeden Tag gut drauf? Ja. Wenn das die Lektion dann ist, dass man einfach jeden Morgen sich kurz jemanden annexen sollte. Also, toller Trip, aber ich weiß nicht, wie ich das bewerten soll, ob ich da in Deutsch schreiben soll, aber dann wird das auch übersetzt von Google Translate. Man weiß es nicht, aber es ist so ein Ding, also, wenn Leute nett zu einem sind, dann kann man das nicht ausschlagen. Auch ein Autorenkollege, ein neuer, war, es war auch interessant, nee, bei einem neuen Projekt jetzt, und dann hat er selbstgepflückte Trauben mitgebracht, wo hat er so hingestellt. Und ich habe halt dieses Trauma bei selbst gepflückten Sachen immer, dass da Maharten drin sind. Ich habe das einfach in mir drin. Immer höre ich das und so und dann habe ich es nicht gegessen und dachte mir, ah shit, du musst essen. Er hat das extra gewaschen, in die Mitte des Tisches gestellt. Und er schiebt es einem immer noch so hin, er schiebt es einem immer näher, die Schlüssel. Nimm doch, nimm doch! Und du musst es essen. Und dann dachte er, oh, bei sich selber, oh, nee, hier war eine Made drin. Und ich schmeiß sie weg. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, Gott sei Dank, der Moment ist vorbei. Nicht nur hatte ich recht, Gott sei Dank ist die Situation auch vorbei. Und dann nachher hat er mir die Schüssel wieder hingeschoben. Als wäre das normal, als wäre das nicht das Furchtbarste, was ich jemals gesehen habe. Und dann habe ich eine genommen und habe wirklich zehn Minuten lang diese eine Traube abgesucht, ob da ein Loch drin ist oder wonach man auch immer sucht. Zwei Löcher. Die kommen ja durch den Ast eigentlich rein. Die kommen durch den Ast rein, aber gehen sie dann durch das gleiche Loch wieder raus? Oder wenn zwei Löcher drin sind, sind dann zwei Maden drin oder ist die Maden wieder raus? Die Blüten da drin oder so, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht, es war sehr unangenehm. Vor allem, wie groß war der Tisch? Weil oft gibt es die Situation, dass Snacks so, dass der Tisch so groß ist, dass das, was in der Mitte des Tisches ist, niemand erreichen kann und es dann so unnötig umständlich wird und dann noch mehr Fokus darauf gelegt wird, dass es niemand will, weil dann reicht dir jemand ganz weit das hin, willst du was, nee danke und dann ah, gib es mal an Ralf. Bitte? Was? Du selbst, der es gar nicht will, muss es dann so curlen und beim Curlen fällt die Hälfte raus und nichts kommt bei Ralf an und dann wieder wir brauchen diesen Schieber und dann kommt die Pustfrau mit dem Besen. Ja, wir brauchen den Schieber und ach, ununfallsbar. Bring niemand will Selbstgemachtes, wirklich, also jetzt mal ein Shoutout, niemand will selbstgemachte Sachen, backt es für euch, backt es für euch und euren Lebensgefährten oder für die Familie, aber nicht für Kollegen, nicht für Leute ausserhalb, es ist immer widerlich, niemand will es, lasst es einfach, es ist immer unangenehm. Wir haben Neuigkeiten. Wir dachten, sie wäre vorbei, die Storyline. Wir haben sie sogar begraben. Wir haben sie sogar begraben, ausgebuddelt und wiederbegraben. Wir buddeln sie noch mal aus. Die WC ist zurück! Nein, es geht weiter! Und zwar dank euch. Ihr seid unseren Wünschen gefolgt und habt ihr nicht mehr geschrieben. Danke dafür. Vielen Dank. Aber wir haben andere tolle News bekommen. Und zwar eine Grafikerin einer Werbeagentur hat uns geschrieben, wir hätten das jetzt raussuchen sollen, egal, sie hat uns geschrieben und hat uns einen Entwurf geschickt, den sie gerade geschrieben hat, den sie gerade entworfen hat, für die WC-Ente, weil sie hat für SC Johnson & Son gearbeitet, eine Grafikerin, Wahnsinn, und sie hat einfach oben, es war quasi so ein neues Produktpaper, ich glaube, vielleicht ist es ist nur intern für die Firma, aber sie hat oben in der Ecke, wo klein die Flasche der WC-Einheit zu sehen war, hat sie das Wort Ente durch Schwan ersetzt. Ja, unfassbar. Sie hat einfach bei einem offiziellen SC Johnson & Son Produkt das einfach geändert ist. Das das sagen eigentlich hier? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Weil ich glaube, dass mittlerweile jeder Mitarbeiter von SC Johnson hier mindestens einmal reingehört hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das sagen darf. Aber ich finde es auch lustig, wenn es aufliegt. Ich finde, also egal in welche Richtung diese Geschichte geht, ich finde es gut, weil wir haben keine Chance. Aber sie hat eine Chance, sie sitzt direkt an der Quelle. Eben, wir müssen da infiltrieren, das ist ja die Idee. Bewerbt euch bei Estee Johnson & Son und wir räumen die Laden von innen auf. Vor allem, also ich glaube gerade, sind denn Fabriken wirklich so gut geschützt, dass man da nicht mal einen Computer kann und da die Grafik ändern kann? Oder ist das so super krass Firmengeheimnis? Ist doch lustig, ist doch eine lustige Bildschlagzeile, wenn du in die WC, nicht, dass ihr das nachmachen sollt, aber schreibt ruhig mal mit. Aber nicht, dass du das machen sollst, Carina, die du da arbeitest, dich einfach mal nachts in die Fabrikhalle schleichst, da an den Rechner gehst, an den Drucker und da einfach die Etiketten änderst. Genau, mal einmal in den WC-Schwan oder überetikettierst. Stell dir mal den Zettel vor, beim Edeka, so Rückruf, 400 Tonnen mussten zurückrufen wegen eines Etikettenfehlers, weil statt WC-Ente WC-Schwan draufstand. Wie gut wäre dieser Zettel bei Edeka? Wie gut wäre das, Carina? Und dann meine ich dich. Naja, das Ding ist ja, und ich glaube, das wäre denen auch zu peinlich, das zu revidieren, und dann sagen die, das ist doch jetzt besser, wenn wir es einfach so lassen. Ja, das ist doch eine Schlagzeile, oder? DVDL greift das auf, WC Enter heißt jetzt die Zehn schlagen. Ach, die greifen nur allen Scheiss auf, ist ja auch nicht mehr zu berichten da draußen. Immer Trump, Trump, Trump, die ganze Zeit Trump, Trump, Trump. Das Sommerloch, ne? Ja, Sommerloch und Trump. Der ist auch, der muss sich auch denken. Geil Sommerloch, jetzt berichtet über mich. Könnte man das mal mal machen, so eine Fake, das hat bestimmt schon ganz viele gemacht, so die Extra-Dreis da draußen, mal so zum Sommerloch irgendwie so den neuen Bären etablieren. Du fälschst Bären-Footage und hast dann so zwei verängstigte Bauern, die sagen, ja, die haben mir den Zaun eingerissen. Dann hast du doch recht schnell eine Schlagzeile Bär, oder? Wir brauchen mal wieder einen Bären. Irgend ein Tier, was wild ist. Ich meine, das kannst du doch heute supergut fälschen, gerade so eine schlechte Bildaufnahme. Kriegt man mal rein. Lass mal hier, du kennst doch den Jan Böhrmann, mach doch mal ein Neomagazin, nächstes Jahr der große Bär. Okay. Eisbär, Eisbär in Deutschland, das wäre eine Schlagzeile. Stimmt. Aber na ja, ist die Frage wegen Klimaerwärmung und so. Ja, oder man nimmt einen Bär und färbt den Weiss. Ich bin offen dafür. Lass uns da mal was überlegen. Aber lass uns mal so einen Bären besorgen, den Weiss färben und dann einfach irgendwo aussetzen. Die Schlagzeilen machen sich von selbst. Und dann, wie ist der so sauber geworden? WC-Ente! Kontra, nee, Nachteil, Gefahr, Bären färben, gleich gefährlich. Naja, das ist jetzt eine Milchmädchenrechnung. Glaubst du, das ist keine Milchmädchenrechnung. Was ist eine Milchmädchenrechnung? Aber dann lass doch für Persil eine Werbung machen, dass der Bär sauber ist. Feste, wo Bär wir? Dann mach doch den Bär weiss und dann heißt es, ah, der ist sauber. Dann hast du wieder Megarassismus weiss. Perl ist Vorwürfe, wie sind braune Menschen etwa dreckig und zack ist Persil, guck mal ein Krott. Da hast du, glaube ich, der rechten Fraktion was in den Mund gelegt. Nee, das ist alles von hier Ferdi Fuchs, der will Persil rauskegeln und macht so eine bewusst rassistische Werbung für Persil. Ja, ich glaube, du machst da ein bisschen was durcheinander. Da gehen jetzt glaube ich gerade die Maskottchen mit dir durch. Der Spähfuchs spricht mit dem. Und der Charmingbär ist weiss. Und der Charmingbär ist braun. Sekunde, der Charmingbär ist plötzlich weiss und Persil sagt, na, da hat er wohl endlich mal mit Persil gewaschen. Oder die Milka-Hente sagt, na ja, oder ihm sind wieder Punkte abhanden gekommen. Und der Kinder-Pinguilöwe kommt um die Ecke und sagt, na, ist das nicht rassistisch? Sind braune Menschen etwa dreckig? Und dann, dann hat Persil nämlich richtigen Ärger. Und dann kommen die Cineminis, ihr Nazi-Schweine, wir machen euch fertig. So der grosse Werbung-Krieg einfach, wo alle Firmen alles rein Material schlachten. Ey, das ist doch die Zukunft für Marvel und den ganzen Scheiss. Einfach so Werbekriege, Cineminis. Haben jetzt Emojis, ne, aber nicht alle. Ne, das stimmt schon, ist mir auch aufgefallen. Ich habe immer nur die traurigen Emojis. Ein guter Start in den Form. Ein guter Start in den Form. Geschockt und dicke Menschen-Emojis auf Cineminis. Ich habe den Diabetes-Emoji. Oh nein, Spritze, schon wieder Spritze. Naja, aber es geht auch weiter. Kevin war nämlich vor Ort bei SC Johnson & Sun. Man weiß nicht warum, aber unsere Hörer treibt es gefährlich nah in die Fabrikgelände. Ja, ja, hoffentlich hat er kein T-Shirt an währenddessen. Und er hat uns ein Foto geschickt. Also kein Podcast-Sufu-T-Shirt. Und er hat uns ein Foto geschickt von dem Eingang. Und zwar steht da SC Johnson & Son beste, ich glaube, beste Arbeitgeber Platz 17. Von? Genau, und dann hat er die gute Frage gestellt, was ist das für ein Unternehmen, dass sie mit Platz 17 werben? Ja. Was ist da vorgefahren? Ja, aber vor allem, also der Welt Deutschlands in der Branche, das muss man doch näher spezifizieren. Die WC-Interview war auch locker irgendwie so ein Nazi, wie Volkswagen so ein Nazi-Unternehmen. Ja, ja, genau. Die hat Hitler auch zur Macht gebracht. Das war auch so ein Ding. Deswegen, das hieß es ja immer, die Deutschen damals hatten gute Panzer und gute WCs, saubere WCs. Ja, die Deutsche ganz. Die Deutsche WC! Haben die WC gesagt oder ist es zu, ist auch französisch, ne? Closet? Water, Closet, ist Französisch, ja.
Ne, ich glaube, die haben weder WC noch Toilette gesagt, die haben Scheisshaus gesagt. Scheisshaus. Ne, was ist das deutsche Wort für ... Locus? Klo. Locus? Ne. Was? Lotus. Das ist eine Pflanze. Tatsächlich, mit dem ich in Frankreich war, der hat erzählt, dass man eine französische Austauschstudentin bei seiner Mutter war. Und seine Mutter kann nicht so gut Französisch oder hat sie sie, bevor sie gefahren ist, nochmal gefragt. Sowas wie ich kann nicht so gut Französisch. Willst du noch ein Jus de Pomme de terre? Also sie hat gefragt, statt willst du noch einen Apfelsaft, hat sie gefragt, willst du noch einen Kartoffelsaft? Pomme de terre, Erdapfel, einfach so die deutscheste Frage der Welt. Bevor du wieder zurück in dein Froschland fährst, willst du noch einen schönen Humpen Kartoffelsaftft und sie non non merci schön urigen kartoffelsalat mit und dann hätte sie was vorgesetzt bekommen was nicht in erwartung entspricht also wirklich dass sowas so was essentielles wie kartoffel pomme du terre heißt immer apfel der erde apfel der Erde. Ja, sollte das andere nicht eher Baumkartoffel heissen. Stimmt, ja. Also da muss man auch flexibel sein, als Sprache muss man da auch flexibel sein. Wie gesagt, also was hatten die gegen das Wort Kartoffel? Haben die dann bewusst gesagt, ich glaube die Sprache, weil ich die Sprachbarriere... Stimmt, die haben kein K, also sie haben kein K. Was? Dast du ja ein C machen. Kartoffel wie Karott? Auch die Japaner haben kein K. Die Japaner haben andere Zeichen. Aber die haben, aber das ist, ich würde ja auch gerne so ein Funfact raushauen, wie, bei denen heißt, ich weiß nicht, Melone, grosser, runde Gurke. Aber das kann ich halt nicht machen. Rurke. Weil ich erkenne noch kein System. Ja, ja, nee, du musst auch, man lernt auch Sprachen nicht, um Funfacts rauszuhauen. Das ist nicht der Sinn der Sache. Nee, damit du die Kultur kennenlernst, damit du dich mit Leuten unterhalten kannst, damit du die original japanische Literatur konsumieren kannst, original schön One Piece. Das erste Wort, was ich gelernt habe, war Teriyaki, Manga, Tempura.
Aber willst du nicht dann, also dann kannst du ja keine Ahnung, Death Note oder Neon Genesis Evangelion oder sowas im Original gucken. Reizt sich das gar nicht? Doch, doch, doch, doch, schon irgendwann. Hast du mal ein Anime gesehen? Ja, also Death Note war ich ein großer Fan von, Death Note ist super gut, also wirklich eine fantastische Prämisse, wer das nicht kennt. Es gibt auch einen Netflix-Film, der schlecht ist. Ich fand ihn gar nicht so schlecht, das erzähl ich da.
Davor habe ich die Manga auch noch nicht, das Anime noch nicht gesehen. Da fand ich ihn ganz okay. Aber das Anime ist wesentlich besser. Dann habe ich, neulich saß jemand neben mir im Zug, und ich mag es ja nicht, wenn jemand auf deinem Bildschirm startet die ganze Zeit, aber ich habe die ganze Zeit auf seinem Bildschirm gestartet, weil er die ganzen fünf Stunden von Berlin nach Köln hat er geschaut, irgendein Basketball-Anime. Ich habe es danach auch nicht gefunden. Also sowas wie Kickers, aber für Basketball. Aber nur für Basketball. Und jede Folge ist ein Basketballspiel. Und man denkt sich, das kann doch nicht ernst sein, dass das die Serie ist. Aber das ist die Serie. Aber vor allem gab es doch auch Volleyball, ne? Ich glaube, es gab auch Fußball, Jungs, Volleyballmädchen. Ja, aber da geht es doch mehr um die Konflikte in der Kabine und wer hat die Frau von dem, oder? Da dauert ein Schuss, zwei Staffeln. Da wird er immer in der Luft rotiert, einfach so 20 Minuten lang. Und du als Kind sitzt da und denkst, ja, ich habe keine Alternative, als das zu sehen gerade. Was soll ich machen? Ja, aber das Basketballding, dachte ich mir die ganze Zeit, was schaust du denn da? Ja, der rollt ja dann so auf dem Ring ganz oft rum, bevor er reingeht. Ja, und das ist lächerlich lang, aber die ganzen fünf Stunden war das dieser Shot, wo noch die letzten zwei Sekunden auf der Uhr waren. Aber Basketball ist doch gar nicht so gut, weil bei Basketball gibt es ja ganz viele Punkte. Ja, und Basketball ist nur 20 Minuten lang. Und gegen ein Tor kann so ein Tor so richtig krass jetzt hin und dann fällt das Tor und dann ist es ja auch spielentscheidend. Aber bei Basketball zack, zack, zack. Aber was mich die meisten verwundert hat, es ging nicht mal um die zwischenmenschlichen Konflikte oder sowas, sondern es ging um Spielzüge. Also da war man wirklich mal einfach zwei Folgen lang gegessen. Also ich habe dann wirklich einfach hingeguckt auch die ganze Zeit. Es war auch untertitelt, das war super für mich zum Mitlesen und zum Mitverfolgen der Sendung. Ganz interessant,
also wer das mal rausfinden könnte, was das
für eine Show war und was da,
wenn man da mal so einen Inhalt einer Staffel
zusammenfassen könnte, wäre ich sehr dankbar.
Naja, also er geht an die rote Linie,
wirft und dann weiß man nicht, ob er trifft.
Es kommt erst in Staffel zwei. Es kommt erst in Staffel
25 raus. Ja genau, aber so
war es ein bisschen. Das ist nicht wie Game of Thrones, wo jede Folge jemand stirbt, nein, da stirbt nie irgendwer. Und es wird einmal das Korb getroffen, vielleicht das Muskottchen. Aber es gibt viel von diesen Sportserien, also ich glaube, es gibt Fußball, Volleyball, Basketball, Eiskunstlauf gibt es auch. In Deutschland, also dafür, dass Deutschland so sportaffin ist, gibt es keine Serie. Ist Deutschland so sportaffin? Naja, Fussball und Bossboy, Baseball.
Was meinst du damit, Basketball?
Baseball, schön die Basis, ja, auf dem Inning.
Die Basis.
So, die Basis, so, das ist ja alles total tief dritten.
Die Basis, versteht sie nicht.
Schießen, Torwand, weglaufen, hinlaufen zu jemandem, von dem wieder weglaufen. Sich verstecken. Ja. Versteckfangen. Genau. Klettern auf den Baum, von dem Baum herab. Mein neues Büro ist der absolute Wahnsinn. Sag nicht dein Büro. Ich habe ein eigenes Büro. Du hast vielleicht ein Zimmer in dem Büro. Ja, nee, nee, nee. Du hast ein eigenes Bürozimmer? Ich teile es mit einem Kollegen.
Das ist nicht dein Büro.
Das ist mein geteiltes Büro.
Jedenfalls gucke ich raus und das Einzige, was ich sehe, ist eine riesen, weil gegenüber von dem Büro auf der Oscar-Jäger-Strasse in Köln ist eine grosse Kletterwand.
Weil gegenüber ist so ein Kletterpark.
Ach ja.
Da kann man rein.
Und ich schaue die ganze Zeit auf diese Kletterwand. Das heißt, den ganzen Tag sehe ich Leute hochklettern. Und wenn die oben sind, lassen sie sich hier fallen, am Seil. Aber jedes Mal geht mein Kopf rüber und ich schreie instinktiv, weil ich gerade jemanden Menschen von einem Gebäude fallen sehe. Und man lernt ja auch nicht dazu. Man rückt Leute so dreissigmal am Tag rüber und sieht halt jemanden fallen. Wie viele Leute kleidern da hoch? Ist da viel Betrieb? Am Tag? Achtzig, fünf, achtzig Leute? Aber das ist so eine ganze... Zwischen achzig und fünfundachtig Leute. Das ist so eine ganze... Ja, was wird das sein? Wie viele Stockwerke hoch ist dieses Kletterding? Drei. Drei Stockwerke? Drei. Und dann will ich, Leute, sie hat was von so einer Zombie-Apokalypse. Also, man sieht das so selten. Eine Hauswand, und du siehst ja auch die Nübel, Nübel nicht von meinem Ort, du siehst einfach nur Leute eine Wand hochkrachzeln. Ich war einmal mit einem Freund von mir, ein intensiver Kletterer ist es auch heute noch, super krass. Und als Kinder ... Die kompensieren doch was, hoch hinaus. Als Kinder kommt man dann halt auch mal mit, so her, hast du mal Lust, Klettertraining zu kommen? Und ich so, ja klar, kein Problem und so. Und dann gibt es dann auch so verschiedene Farben, so verschiedene schwierige Routen. Und ich dachte mir, ach cool, okay, und er klettert mal hoch und so, ja, musst du da aufpassen. Und ich bin nicht die erste Sprosse hochgekommen. Ich bin nicht mal die, ich war so fett und meine Hände waren so klein und dick, ich hab's nicht geschafft, die erste Spross hochzukommen. Und dann war halt so die Situation, okay, ich geh dann wieder nach Hause, ja? Tschüss, bis morgen in der Schule und wirklich, ich war zwei Minuten in dieser Kletterhalle und er war da halt noch der Rest der Kletterstunde und ich bin nach Hause gerollt, einfach alleine. Ja, das ist so ein Ding, wenn man dann sofort merkt, das ist nichts für einen. Ich will ja unbedingt mal Kart fahren und dann denke ich mir, ich werde in diesen Kart steigen und ich werde zu groß dafür sein. Machen wir uns nichts vor, ich bin zwei Meter gross, diese Karts sind für Leute, die 1,30 groß sind. Ich werde zu groß dafür sein und werde enttäuscht nach Hause fahren, bin dann aber halt da und habe die Bahn eine Stunde gemietet. Was macht man da? Ich kriege mal das Geld zurück, das wird auch eine Enttäuschung, eine Riesenentäuschung. Ich würde gerne mal Kart fahren gehen. Wir gehen mal schon Lasertag spielen, das ist krass. Hey, ich gehe gerne Lasertag spielen. Mittlerweile bin ich auch relativ gut im, ich habe häufig Lasertag gespielt. Gott, das ist ein kompletter Bluff. Habe ich noch mal erzählt, am besten gegen die Stimmt, ich glaube, das habe ich verdrängt. Gegen die Inklusionsmädchen aus der Nachbarstadt. Nee, gegen die Sprachbehinderten Spanier habe ich doch gespielt. Das klingt gerade wie so eine RTL-Show. Und dann die Sprachbehinderten Spanier. Aber die Sprachbehinderten Spanier, und dann dieses Erklärvideo. Die können sich auch nicht vorspielen. Wir sind die Sprachbehinderten Spanier. Und die haben es weder, also dieses Erklärungsvideo am Anfang, wo man dann, wo so eine reißerische Stimme sagt, na, bereit Team für eure Mission, dann setzt euch jetzt die besten auf. Dieses Video haben die halt nicht, weder auf Spanisch noch auf der spanisch gehörlosen Variante, warum auch? Und dann bin ich wirklich, wie lange geht es so, wie lange geht es so, zehn Minuten lang gegen diese Span... Also die waren auch nicht schnell waren ja, und es war furchtbar, es war Tappen auch so leid, dann habe ich mich irgendwann ergeben, weil, die haben das Spiel auch nicht verstanden. Er ist schon tot, Stefan, er ist schon tot. No, no, no. No, no, gracias. No, no, gracias. Ja, was will man denn sagen? Man weiss ja nicht, was man sagt. Dankeschön. Nee, die sagen ja auch nichts. Dankeschön. Wir sprechen kein Deutsch. Also auch deren Gebärdensprache war ja auch Spanisch. Also viel Gesten, viel Aiaiai, viel Storero, viel Stirngesten. Naja, es war ein weirdes Unterfangen, aber ich bin gespannt. Können wir gerne mal machen. Schön, Leseteckchen. Ja? Ja, ist toll. Wir müssen uns irgendwas richtig Geiles für Folge 150 überlegen. Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt 143. Oh, verdammt. 150 steht um die Ecke, ihr wisst es. Das könnte sogar eine Live-Folge sein. Könnte eine Live-Folge sein. Dann gehen wir alle in die Lasertag-Halle. In Wien sind wir eh nur zu zehnt. Wir machen in Wien schönes Saarlicht aus. Jeder kriegt einen Laserpointer. In Wien ist alles egal. In Wien geht es ab. Wirklich wirklich, Wien wird richtig gut. Ja, wir sind zu 10, wir machen uns einen schönen Abend. Auch so mal näher rücken oder so, wir können da ein paar Stühle anzünden, dann machen wir so eine schöne Atmosphäre. Ja, genau, da können wir mal euch kennenlernen da draußen. Dann kommt ihr mal auf die Bühne und erzählt mal uns, wann ist das für eure... Das ist, glaube ich, egal. Ich glaube, auf der Bühne steht auch mehr als im Publikum sitzen. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist dann auch egal. Dann lassen wir uns dann die Mikros, machen wir dann aus. Ist ja auch irgendwann seltsam, weil irgendwann, ich hätte immer so einen Stand-up-Auftritt, wo sehr wenige im Raum sitzen und irgendwann sprichst du einfach, also wenn du, egal wie klein der Raum ist, wenn du eine gewisse Publikumsgröße hast, ist es okay, dass du mit denen über das Mikrofon sprichst. Irgendwann, wenn zwei Leute vor dir sitzen, denkst du, ja, man muss einfach diesen Tisch drüben setzen und ich erkläre euch, was ich meine.
Wir gehen nochmal Gag für Gag durch alles.
Stattdessen habe ich ein Mikro, diese ganze Technik, die gerade zwischen uns steht, dieses Mikrofon, dass ich reinsprache hier. Der Promter, ja. Dass ich nicht weiss, wie es funktioniert. Dann die Boxen und so, das ist alles zu viel. Sparen wir uns das alles. Komm, wir gehen kurz raus, eine Rauche und ich erzähle euch das. Machst du das noch, Stand-up? Kann man dich noch manchmal antreffen in Kölner Clubs? Nee, ja, vielleicht mal Ende des Jahres, da habe ich wieder viel Zeit, aber jetzt gerade habe ich absolut keine Zeit, keine Zeit, gar nicht. Deswegen bestätige Termine. Wenn ich sage, 20.30 Uhr, bestätige den Termin. Hast du den bestätigt? Nicht, wenn wir davor schnell hin und her schreiben, dann ist das nicht nötig. Das stimmt. Ich bin neulich mit einem anderen Comedy-Autoren, den ich gar nicht gut kenne, aus einer anderen Branche, einer von Luke, ich kann auch Tommy Schmidt, der hat auch einen Demo-Podcast, zusammen mit Felix Lobrecht, gemischtes Hack. Hört mal vielleicht rein, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das empfehlen kann, ich habe noch nicht so oft reingehört, aber hört mal rein, mit dem habe ich geschrieben und wie man das kennt, also wie man das auch von dem anderen, wenn man sich nicht gut kennt und man weiß vom anderen, der ist auch Comedy-Autor dann schreibt man halt liney, man wird jokey, man schreibt lustige Sachen. Und irgendwann waren wir in diesem Schnellfeuer-Facebook-Chat gefangen, aus dem du ja nicht mehr rauskommst. Und wann treffen wir uns jetzt? Irgendwann muss dann irgendjemand der Uncool sein. Und dann haben wir angefangen, immer einen draufzusetzen und so, weil man will ja auch besser sein als der andere, man will lustiger sein. Und jemand hat geschrieben, was er lustig fand, das ist auch so ein Gespräch, aus dem man ganz schlecht wieder rauskommt, oder? Er hat es dann angesprochen, was ich gut fand. Und ich dachte mir, das Lustigste ist doch, wenn ich jetzt darauf nicht mehr antworte. Und ich habe auf dem Satz, aus diesem Gespräch kommt man nicht mehr gut raus, bis heute nicht geantwortet. Sehr schön. Und fand es lustig. Und da habe ich ihn irgendwann getroffen auf einer Party und er hat gesagt, er hat es verstanden.
Weil es ist schwierig, wenn der Gag darin besteht, nichts zu tun. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ja, ja. Es ist schwierig herauszufinden, ob er angekommen ist, aber er ist angekommen. Sehr gut. Sehr schön. Ja, das ist lustig. Deswegen, es macht Spaß, mit Leuten zu schreiben, die eine ähnliche Humorphilosophie haben. Und dafür muss man kein Comedy-Autor sein. Dafür muss man einfach durch die Welt gehen, mit einem Lachen im Gesicht. Auch ihr könnt Stefan Tietze schreiben. Schreibt Stefan Tietze an mit lustigen Sprüchen, lustigen Gags, schreibt ihn Leini an und er hat immer Zeit, da irgendwie mit euch in einem humoristischen Fechtkampf sich einzulassen. Und das macht immer Spaß. Das Einzige, was ich damit sagen wollte, ist, lasst uns einfach alle Podcasts aufhören, lasst uns einfach alle mit einem Lächeln durch die Welt gehen. Okay. Darauf
kommt's doch. Alles klar, das ist ein guter Abschluss.
Dafür ist der Podcast auch da.
Vielen Dank, Stefan. Haut rein, macht's gut,
bis nächste Woche. Wir heben ab.
Es gibt noch ein paar Tickets aus der Mannheim, Hamburg,
ein paar, guckt mal, ansonsten sind noch ein paar da,
falls ihr noch Vatertagsgeschenke braucht oder
sowas. Guckt rein, ansonsten macht's gut,
bis nächste Woche. Wir heben ab, macht's gut.
Ciao! .